KITT how high can we get this all those
eyes want to go oh okay okay great
oh you got 48 hours until the shares
never available again from the moment of
this upload go get this shirt Oh
seriously you're watching this video
this is your last chance to buy the
shirt right now it's your last chance if
you don't click on the link right now
buy the shirt it's done so we got a
black magic micro Cinema Camera
it uses micro four-thirds lenses we
don't own any micro four-thirds lenses
solution Micro Four Thirds the Canon
adapter courtesy of aperture Micro for
those lenses protect a smaller image
circle Canon lenses projecting a larger
image circle what does that mean it
means that a wide-angle Canon lens on a
Micro Four Thirds sensor ends up looking
like a telephoto lens and ends up
looking really zoomed in Deborah here
has a piece of glass in it that will re
widen the image so wide-angle Canon lens
will still keep a wide-angle image on a
Micro Four Thirds sensor oh you can also
pull focus and adjust your aperture
wirelessly oh my god it's so much
smaller seats it's got a little lens in
it
you know how to use this lineup red dots
I'm gonna keep all of this there are you
yeah that's cool Oh Stan so this will
Amanda mounting to the side of our
little cage wait do you need you need
this on here yes
[Applause]
it's no longer the Blackmagic micro now
okay man what are we missing out on the
new ones serious work and we're like two
people trying to put one camera together
Sam unboxed the epic ooh when you left
the boxes all laying around including
the pollak and the sticker is the manual
he also left his car keys so I took his
car keys
facing out birkoff
okay
I just saw Sam's keys in his back pocket
I have Nico's keys
okay you saw nothing you saw nothing
did I explain to you the shot I think I
did it it's basically a series of five
shots so yeah this is the perfect time
because the last time we got it the Sun
didn't exist on that wide open shot yeah
the overcast yeah
god I've shot so much stuff in that
bridge over the years over 40 years I've
shot down in the river one of the scenes
on the lost future films I did where I
had a girl trapped by a serial killer in
the tunnel itself and that square tunnel
we built a chain-link fence and we had
her tied up on the fence oh wow
and the cops showed up and they're down
in the tunnel and all of a sudden they
shined their lights up and she's
spread-eagle chained to this fence that
he's built at the end of the tunnel oh
we have God we were shooting there for
like four or five nights which was just
oh my god that's really difficult let's
walk around over to the
hi Cindy
how are you happy birthday leo we are
we're getting some drunk shots at the
hotel this year is my 40th year downtown
and today is my 32nd wedding anniversary
I've been on the planet now well I keep
it a secret but and don't edit don't put
this in it but I have been around for
let me see when I was god
they were just settling New York the in
New York had no buildings on it I was
one of the Indians I'm a descendant of
one of the Indians and we you know we
got a bunch of beads no I'm actually
heart Cherokee Italian German Mexican
mix all that together and you get
immunity you get them yet I see you get
the American Canadian tuxedo exactly
well no no no see I've got a jacket that
this should be worn with this you
talking about my keys oh those are my
keys II found on the table aren't they
ah where do you put them where did you
put my car keys
I think hot or cold pull warmer or
colder freezing warmer freezing okay so
today what we're doing is we're getting
some shots of the American Hotel this
hotel is 111 years old we are in the
first African American neighborhood in
Los Angeles this we're in it that hotel
was built because African Americans
could not legally rent a place to rest
their heads in and that is why I think
this is an important documentary because
this neighborhood has seen so many
incredible changes first it was black
then it was all Japanese when the
Japanese were literally taken out in a
two-week period of time out of that
hotel and sent to concentration camps it
then turned black again for a few years
and then went Hispanic and then became
artists which are predominantly white
are were at the time of the late 70s
freezing freezing warmer nice summer day
here now
all right I go plank the goal of today
is to getting a drone shot about a
thousand feet up above the hotel so that
the building literally looms larger as
we get closer to it
[Music]
that's a great justice right out
oh my god just do that just keep going
oh damn that's hot
oh yeah it looks beautiful
you're on the skyline it's perfectly
centered okay I see tail credits coming
up I see images coming up I see at the
end and
go back down to the Filner hole yeah
built American Hotel hold on - that's
okay that's okay okay I think I think we
got it
cool I think we got it enjoy your shot
Wi-Fi huh when do you think you're
losing done I'm hoping within the next
few months it's 120 minutes long tails
of the American it's told like a book
I've already got a distribution deal for
Hulu Vudu Comcast a bunch of digital
platforms but it's going to open up
hopefully at the Downtown independent
theatrical on the big screen so we're
gonna see these shots Oh seriously
seriously I thought you left that there
a purpose I just put this shirt we got
to shoot that first stuff again why
right what Zoey barkow boy what are
these white Carmichael why didn't you
tell me I was I thought you purposely
put that there why would I do that